[الموسيقى]
والأخبار الصحية ، يمكن لعقار مضاد للسرطان
موجود بالفعل في السوق أن
يغير الطريقة التي يعالج بها الأطباء
المرضى المصابات بسرطان الثدي ، كما يقول
الباحثون ، وعادة ما يتم
وصف her2 لمرضى سرطان الثدي الذين ثبتت إصابتهم
بنوع معين من
البروتين ولكن  وجدت دراسة جديدة أن
المرضى الذين كانوا سلبيين بالنسبة
للبروتين ولكن تم إعطاؤهم الدواء على أي حال
يعيشون لفترة أطول ويظل سرطانهم
تحت السيطرة لفترة أطول ، يقول المحقق الرئيسي
في التجربة إن هذا
قد يفتح خيارًا علاجيًا جديدًا
للمرضى ولكن هناك بعض الأمان
مخاوف بما في ذلك
مرض رئوي مميت يُعرف بأنه مرتبط
بالدواء الذي تم دفع ثمن البحث من أجله
يجب أن تعرفه الشركة المصنعة للأدوية
وتم نشره في مجلة الطب الجديدة في إنجلترا